I just feel like we've drifted apart
ever since my burrito podcast started to take off.
But I love your podcast.
I just don't...think you love it for the right reasons.
I love burritos.
Not enough.
All right boys, she's single.
Lets get to work.  What's in the pantry, Phil?
Uh, we got Doritos, queso, and
Oh!  Two boxes of Debbie Little Cakes.
We're good.
What kind of Doritos?
Uh, Cool Ranch.
Good.
Mitch, what are we looking like on the Blue-Ray
Rom-Com situation?
Uh, pretty comprehensive collection here.
We have the Notebook, some early Aniston flicks,
and Clueless if she's feeling nostalgic.
Lets get her some Joseph Gordon Levitt.
What she needs right now is something quarky and charming.
Copy that, Jogo Labs coming in hot.
Phil.
Yeah?
Download the dating app.
Uh, it's too soon for that, isn't it?
Now dammit!
Yeah!  Okay, uh.  We've got the Tinder App downloading
It's at 30%.
It's at 80%.
Dammit ma'am, she's not going to hold.
Yes she will!  She's strong!
Mitch!  Get that God-damn burrito out of her hand!
Aye-aye Cap!
100%!  Tinder App download is complete.
It's cat time first.
Meow meow.
Aww.
Ma'am, we have got a flood of dick pics coming in
ever since we changed the Facebook status to single.
Show me!
Maybe it's time for a rebound?
What did you say?
Rebound.
Say it again and I'll rebound your nuts in my drawer.
Oh, we got a match!
Actually we've got 368 matches since we downloaded this.  Jesus.
Well you know a lot fo dudes are just playing the numbers.
Because it works.
Haha, fucking A it works.
You guys are in a girl's head.
Could you fucking act like it?
Sorry, ma'am.
Oh, we actually have a decent match here.
Uh, except uh...
What is it?  What's wrong?
He's a ginger.
Well...
What the Hell, right?
Good job boys!  She made it out of there alive!
Nice!
Mitch, pull some of the dick picks on screen.
Ma'am, I deleted those.
Oh.
Good.
That was a test.
Hey!  Don't pick up your curling iron by the hot part.
It hurts a lot.
May 18th is when my clothing line
Ghost and Stars launches.
If you are so inclined to check it out.
May 29th I am doing stand up comedy 7PM
at the Nerdmelt showroom.
I may or may not be doing stand up as my Asian character
if you want to know you'll just have to come!
And finally, thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring today's episode.
With Squarespace, you can make a sleek, modern
website.  They've got drag and drop!
Ow, ow!
They've got drag and drop.  They've got really cool landing pages!
Free trial, no credit card down, for only $8 a month.
What?!
You can go to Squarespace.com/Anna for 10% off
of building your very own website.
All right, bye!